und wir berichten über einen
polizeieinsatz der völlig aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist und rausgekommen ist das
nur weil es ein videobeweis gibt diesen
videobeweis hier sehen sie ja das ist
eine verkehrskontrolle so steht's im
polizeibericht aber in wahrheit eine
wilde jagd auf zwei rollerfahrern
äußerst rabiate einsatz wie dieses video
dann zeigt dem polizeibericht stand von
dieser art des eingreifens allerdings
nichts
ein einsatzwagen der polizei überholt
den mofa fahrer scherte nach rechts auf
den radweg macht eine vollbremsung
der mofa und mitfahrer haben keine
chance karten auf das heck des bands im
bericht der bielefelder polizei vom 15
august steht dass der 20 jährige
bielefelder beschleunigt und versucht
von einer geplanten fahrzeugkontrolle
davon zu fahren und weiter dabei
wechselte er von der fahrbahn auf den
gehweg die beamten überholten den fahrer
erneut wobei sie den roller für kurze
zeit aus den augen verloren als sie das
fahrzeug langsam seitig abstellten
hörten sie nach kurzer zeit einen
auftrag der 20 jährige war mit dem
roller in das heck des streifenwagens
gefahren so sieht also langsam seitlich
abstellen bei diesen drei bielefelder
polizeibeamten aus ein anwohner hat den
vorfall gefilmt das video geht viral
haben die polizeibeamten extra einen
gefährliche unfall gebaut um den
mofafahrer zu überwältigen und dann auch
noch versucht das ganze zu vertuschen
nrw-innenminister herbert reul kündigt
gegenüber bild aufklärung an auf den
ersten blick ergeben sich aus dem video
deutliche zweifel an der polizeilichen
vorgehensweise sollte sich zudem
herausstellen dass beamte den
sachverhalt hier bewusst anders
dargestellt haben als er war hat das
natürlich konsequenzen auch polizisten
dürfen fehler machen aber ich erwarte
von polizisten dass sie zu ihren fehlern
stehen wie immer gilt es aber die
ermittlungsergebnisse abzuwarten bevor
man urteilt in einem aktualisierten
polizeibericht der bielefelder beamten
heißt es nun am montag dem 25 22 erhielt
die polizei bielefeld kenntnis von einem
video das einen zusammenstoss eines
rollers mit einem streifenwagen zeigt
auch wenn die authentizität des videos
bisher nicht abschließend geprüft werden
konnte geht die polizei bielefeld von
der echtheit der inhalte aus sie bilden
die grundlage für die weiteren
bewertungen und maßnahmen wie sich
später herausstellt ist der mofa fahrer
mit einem getunten zweirad und unter
drogeneinfluss gefahren für die
polizisten hat das langsam seitliche
abstellen konsequenzen
die drei beamten wurden in den
innendienst versetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
und jetzt live von sa bild chefreporter
frank schneider der diesen fall ganz
genau kennen ich grüße dich fragen was
veranlasst polizisten zu seinem
eingreifen
ja das ist die große frage und dass sie
offenbar schlechtes gewissen haben zeigt
sich ja daran dass der polizeibericht
nicht dem entsprach was wirklich
passiert ist wie haben sie ein video
gesehen und ein langsames seitliches
abstellen wenn ich die beiden verfolgten
aus den augen verloren hat sieht
natürlich komplett anders aus es würde
zum beispiel eine situation geben können
die das rechtfertigt wenn zum beispiel
dieser roller fahrer tagsüber über den
gehweg fährt fußgänger gefährt über rote
ampeln fährt das heißt ein hohes risiko
besteht dass unbeteiligte verletzt gar
getötet werden dann könnte es natürlich
einen grund geben dass man so radikal
und robust eingreift aber in dem fall
ist ja wohl so gewesen auch wenn man
dort über den gehweg fährt tief in der
nacht dort sind keine fußgänger dass
dieses eingreifen doch wohl offenbar
übertrieben war und man muss noch eins
sagen gerade bei so einem bully es ist
ja genau das würdest du mit diesem
roller vor einer wand fahren und auch
wenn die beiden jugendlichen oder jungen
männer helme getragen haben ist
natürlich das verletzungsrisiko und
schweres verletzungsrisiko und natürlich
deutlich erhöht wir können nur froh sein
dass den beiden nicht viel passiert ist
trotzdem darf man nicht außer acht
lassen dass die beiden vorher natürlich
auch mist gebaut haben auf gut deutsch
aber ob das jetzt wie gesagt dieses
eingreifen rechtfertigten bestehen große
zweifel
wir erleben dass in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten immer wieder frank
dass dann der videobeweis sozusagen
anschließend kommt das eben hin die
videos auftauchen und auch an die
öffentlichkeit gelangen was bedeutet das
für die polizei gestellt die sich darauf
ein
naja sind an dem fall videos die polizei
nicht selber gemacht hat oder mit denen
sie nicht rechnen konnte oder musste das
ist glaube ich schon mal ein großer
fehler bei polizisten heute wird vieles
gefilmt immer mit den handys
draufgehalten natürlich tief in die
nacht rechne man möglicherweise nicht
damit was man aber jetzt auch noch
erklären muss genau wie s body kenne ich
bei der polizei gibt gibt es eigentlich
bei streifenwagen gerade bei
einsatzfahrten eine kamera vorne im auto
und zwar hinter dem spiegel hinter dem
rückspiegel und ob diese kann man jetzt
eingeschaltet war oder nicht eigentlich
wird die automatisch aktiviert bei einer
verfolgungsfahrt das muss man jetzt noch
mal abschließend klären denn darauf
könnte man ja sehen dass das kein
langsames seitliches abstellen ist denn
wie der in die bremsen geht das hört man
ja alleine wie das abs anspringt wie es
trotzdem quietscht immer wieder ganz
kurz mit den reifen das zeigt eben also
wie robust er da rechts mehr oder
weniger den roller ausgebremst hat und
warum es dieses video nicht gibt oder
noch nicht ausgewertet das hier sehen
wir uns nochmal und hören es ja auch das
quietschen und dann kommt sofort zum
aufprall das muss man jetzt nochmal
klären denn dafür sind die kameras ja
eigentlich da um auf der einen seite
rechtmäßig verhalten zu dokumentieren
damit die polizisten sich hinterher
keinen unnötigen vorwürfen ausgesetzt
sehen aber auch auf der anderen seite
durch fehlverhalten zu dokumentieren und
hier ist ja so gewesen dass die beamten
ganz offensichtlich selber wussten dass
das mist war so greifen normalerweise
spezialeinheiten ein wenn sie räuber
geldautomaten sprenger in der nacht oder
ähnliches verfolgen damit sie nicht mehr
entkommen können aber hier handelt sich
immerhin nur um zwei rollerfahrer auch
wie gesagt auch wenn sie vom auto
drogeneinfluss einem getunten roller
unterwegs waren aber da darf man du dich
nicht in kauf nehmen dass den
jugendlichen möglicherweise ganz
schlimmes passiert bis möglicherweise
auch bis hin zur tötung und genau dass
es in diesem fall passiert sagt er an
unserem bild chefreporter frank
schneiden
[Musik]